welcome back you're looking live at the
funeral procession of George fluid in
Houston Texas a very emotional day for
his family and his friends Floyd's death
igniting a nationwide debate over police
reform president Trump set to unveil a
series of proposals as soon as this week
while many in the Democratic Party
pushed back against calls to defund the
police the movement facing blowback
across the political spectrum top
Democrats are trying to distance
themselves from it including presumptive
Democratic nominee Joe Biden I don't
support defunding the police I support
conditioning federal aid the police
based on whether or not they meet
certain basic standards of decency on
honorable lists and in fact are able to
demonstrate they can protect the
community and everybody in the community
but some leaders like the Minneapolis
City Council president continue to call
for dismantling the police I think the
idea of having a police free future is
very operational the command that we
need is clearly a long-term commitment
our Police Department has been in place
for 150 years we cannot take 150 years
to solve this problem but we absolutely
will need to build up those systems of
Public Safety as the highest priority as
the very first priority along with
getting more accountability in our
police department today all right Dana
what kind of political position does
this put Democrats in who are you know I
think nationally trying to distance
themselves from the defund the police
movement but you have a very very vocal
minority of people on the fringes that
are screaming pretty loudly about this
and are not backing down it's very
interesting so Speaker Pelosi when she
was asked about it yesterday when they
introduced the Democrats ideas for
reform policing she was asked about it
and she said well that's a local matter
but that's it's it's not just a local
matter I mean they basically they
painted it on the street of Washington
DC and they're having to answer these
questions for
they obviously would prefer that they
didn't have to deal with the fringe
coming up with this idea that do you
fund the police but you're actually
having conversations now I heard a
couple of podcast today where I wanted
to understand what do they do they
really mean like there would be no
police and this this idea for example
that you would have a social worker
respond without any protection to a
domestic violence call now I could I can
see that you wouldn't want to escalate
things but what if the domestic violence
call is in fact violent and you have to
protect the police officer or the person
then it is being victimized I mean a lot
of this it doesn't make sense you pull
on the thread and it's not there I do
think that there will be some
progressives who will get frustrated
with the Democratic establishment and
the prospective nominee Joe Biden for
not taking them seriously
they are gonna try to water down as we
said yesterday that they don't really
mean to fund the police like some of
them actually do but I think in the long
run the police departments are not going
to be defunded they might be reformed
but I think cooler heads will prevail in
the end yeah I would agree with that
kill me do you think that Joe Biden
risks being pulled really far to the
left because he really does have to
cater to this defund the police movement
and he's having some trouble kind of
articulating exactly what that means
could he get bogged down in something
like this Jessi there's no question
about it or should I say Watters there's
no question about it because we see
people going way to the left and
everybody else who's not going way to
the left tries to bow out of it artfully
like Nancy Pelosi but the one thing Joe
Biden has and even the Washington Post
pointed out today is he's got a past and
in his past he's tough on crime and he
is not really worried about people's
economic circumstances or the situation
with the color of people's skin he came
out with that crime bill he was behind
it he campaigned on it he was proud of
it and he was running on it until he got
the nomination now and he suddenly says
to himself I hope nobody has Google but
to see where
stood on this for the last 40 years
until recently so I think he's got a
huge issue the other problem I have is
Minneapolis New York and Los Angeles
I've already made moves to defund the
police so you're not happy with their
performance so let them perform with
less less people less equipment less
financing worse uniforms maybe worse
guns so let's just take a look at these
cities New York City shootings have
increased 18% burglaries 31% carjacking
64% good to know car jackings back
Minneapolis carjackings up 45% homicides
up 60% burglaries up 28% and we know
what goes on in Los Angeles where the
police union came out and said are you
kidding me we got 10,000 police and
policemen here we are overwhelmed and
now you're cutting our budget and
calling us killers so thanks a lot
there's a reality and there's rhetoric
the reality is there's not going to be a
person in this country who's gonna want
to be a cop after a while it there's not
a lot of glory in it these days that's
right and as you could see there the
funeral procession is exiting off of the
highway and we're gonna stay close on
that and keep you posted on what happens
as George Floyd is going to be laid to
rest in a little while Juan Williams
just picking up on what Kilmeade just
mentioned it doesn't bother you at all
that that some of these things came out
of this legitimate movement that are so
silly you know I looked at some of the
fine print with the defund the police
they're talking about decriminalizing
prostitution you know sending a
therapist to a crime scene really really
ridiculous things does that take away
from this movement in your opinion when
you add that to all the looting and the
violence that took place I think that's
a distortion of this moment I mean you
know to my mind if if we on the five
we're discussing left-wing democratic
politics I think we'd say Bernie Sanders
could personify that and what did Bernie
Sanders say today he's not at all
engaged with defund
the police he thinks that's not a good
idea he said a non-starter and what
Bernie Sanders is saying is we have to
find more effective ways of defining
what we mean by policing that's Bernie
Sanders far-left democratic politics
you're hearing much the same from Joe
Biden from Nancy Pelosi from the mayor
of Minneapolis you know and everybody's
saying we have to respond to the George
Floyd situation but it's not about
saying oh there's not going to be any
police instead people are thinking about
well how do you do this more effectively
because if someone has a mental health
issue sending someone with a gun might
not be the best way to deal with it
there may be that that it may be the
case that that person becomes violent
and at which point you do want to send a
police officer but again is it the case
that we want to strengthen something
like mental health services or for drug
addicts we want to strengthen drug
treatment programs this is a kind of
more sophisticated way and not putting
police on what is really not should not
be police work in the country so I think
that there's it's important to
understand that even as you can you know
sort of caricature defund the police and
make it an argument it's a distortion
from the reality of the kind of
conversation even the kind of
legislation that we're seeing on Capitol
Hill where they're talking about no
choke holes not allowing people not
allowing the police just to know not
just rush in your house and in the case
of Brianna Taylor killer or you know
increased data on use of excessive force
by police so that we can properly as a
society track what's going on and not
allow the police to be belittled or
charged with things that are not fear
this is all part of making us better and
I don't think that it's fair to say say
oh it's all about some loons on the left
as I said even the people we would
identify as the far left are not
embracing this yeah then that's what I'm
trying to reconcile because you know
this is the fine print from the black
lives matter movement this is what the
City Council for many Apple
is saying they want this was ground zero
so I'm not distorting it I think we're
just reporting what's kind of bubbled up
from this movement and what has bubbled
up as as you say correctly is very very
fringe
dagen you know we talked a lot about Joe
Biden and we talked a lot about Bernie
Sanders and Nancy Pelosi the president
obviously has has to release some
reforms pretty soon within the next
couple days how do you think he's
handled the last week or so at some
point the American people need to hear
from President Trump in a carefully
worded message of to use a word I used
when we started the show of healing here
but also what are you going to do in
terms of police reforms one mentioned
mental health congressman will Hurd
wrote an editorial a few days ago in The
Wall Street Journal and pointed out that
ten percent of police calls and more
than one-quarter of fatal police
shootings involve a person with a mental
illness yet most states only require
officers to undergo less than eight
hours of training in handling these
situations but very often when money is
funneled into mental health services
like here in New York City with thrive
NYC which is run by the mayor's wife she
and the mayor spent a billion dollars on
that Mental Health Initiative and
couldn't even account for the number of
people it helped or even how they helped
them so again that's what happens when
people start talking about we're gonna
take money from police departments and
move it into social services New York
already tried that experiment and the
murder rate thirty years ago was more
than six times higher than it is right
now it was only the addition of six
thousand police officers by Mayor David
Dinkins at the time and then the
introduction of rigorous policing and
responsibility and accountability
through CompStat but locally what is
very dangerous and it's happening in New
York that's going on is the the
dangerous fallacy
crimes are victimless that's the message
that was sent by the bail reform here in
New York if you go down the list of
crimes where people are arrested and
don't have to put up any bail it's it's
changed slightly they've tried to tweak
it but if you go down the list of crimes
try aggravated assault of a child under
the age of 11 you don't have to put up
bail and then you also have in San
Francisco the new DA they are
eliminating cash bail and stop
prosecuting what they call victimless
crimes guess what every crime has a
victim if you get punched in the face in
New York City and sent to the emergency
room there's no bail for that that perp
there's no bail for that criminal if a
store gets robbed there's no bail for
that criminal that's got to change and
that's where the danger lies it is in
how local authority is the most
progressive of the left or handling
crime in this nation yeah I would agree
with that we're monitoring the funeral
procession of George Floyd stay with the
fire